Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the eve of nationwide victory in the Chinese Revolution, comrade Mao Zedong called on the whole party to start learning afresh. We did that pretty well, and consequently, after entering the cities, we were able to rehabilitate the economy very quickly and then to accomplish the socialist transformation. But we must admit that we have not learned well enough in the subsequent years. Expending our main efforts on political campaigns, we did not master the skills needed to build our country.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在中国革命全国胜利前夕，毛泽东同志号召全党重新学习。我们做得相当不错，因此在进入城市后，我们能够非常迅速地恢复经济，进而完成社会主义改造。但我们必须承认，在随后的几年里，我们学得还不够好。我们把主要精力花在政治运动上，却没有掌握建设国家所需的技能。
Our socialist construction failed to progress satisfactorily, and we experienced grave setbacks politically. Now that our task is to achieve modernisation, our lack of the necessary knowledge is even more obvious. So, the whole party must start learning again. We should learn in different ways, through practice, from books, and from the experience, both positive and negative, of others as well as our own. Conservatism and book worship should be overcome. So long as we unite as one, work in concert, emancipate our minds, use our heads, and try to learn what we did not know before, there is no doubt that we will be able to quicken the pace of our new long march. Under the leadership of the Central Committee and the State Council,
我们的社会主义建设未能取得令人满意的进展，我们在政治上也遭受了严重的挫折。现在我们的任务是实现现代化，我们缺乏必要知识的问题就更加明显了。因此，全党必须重新开始学习。我们应该通过不同的方式学习，通过实践学习，从书本中学习，并从他人以及我们自己的经验（无论是正面的还是负面的）中学习。必须克服保守主义和本本主义。只要我们团结一致，齐心协力，解放思想，开动脑筋，努力学习我们以前不懂的东西，毫无疑问，我们就一定能够加快我们新的长征步伐。在党中央和国务院的领导下，
let us advance courageously to change the backward condition of our country and turn it into a modern and powerful socialist state. So, Tom Holland, that was Deng Xiaoping on the 13th of December 1978, the man who was to transform China so radically that, Tom, I think it's reasonable to argue, isn't it, that he is one of the two or three most significant figures in our lifetime, maybe of the last century, you could argue. I think you could certainly argue that. And it's evident just from reading the newspapers every day just how profound the transformation that China has affected, basically since the death of Chairman Mao, who was alluded to in the passage you read. Because the incredible conjuring trick that the
让我们勇敢地前进，改变我国落后的面貌，把它变成一个现代化的社会主义强国。那么，汤姆·霍兰，那是1978年12月13日的邓小平，他将如此彻底地改变中国，汤姆，我认为有理由认为，他是我们有生之年，甚至可能是上个世纪，最重要的两三个人物之一。我想你肯定可以这样认为。而且，仅仅从每天阅读报纸就能明显看出，自毛主席去世（你刚才读的那段话中提到了他）以来，中国所发生的变革是多么深刻。因为中国共产党所施展的令人难以置信的魔术，
Chinese Communist Party has done is to affect all kinds of capitalist wheezes and maneuvers while remaining overtly communist. And so the question of just how capitalist is modern China, just how communist is it? What is the inheritance from the communist past? What is the inheritance from the deeper past? It's such a fascinating, fascinating question. I think we should put our hands up and admit, not questions that we are ideally qualified to answer. Although, of course, everybody is fascinated by that question, but we have the ideal person to answer those questions for us. He's very much a friend of the show, Rana Mitter, who currently is Professor of the History and Politics of Modern China at Oxford,
就是在中国共产党依然公开坚持共产主义的同时，实施了各种资本主义的权宜之计和策略。那么问题来了，现代中国到底有多资本主义？它又有多共产主义？从共产主义过去中继承了什么？从更深远的过去中又继承了什么？这是一个非常、非常引人入胜的问题。我想我们应该举手承认，这些问题我们并不是最理想的回答人选。当然，每个人都对这个问题着迷，但我们有最理想的人选来为我们解答。他是本节目的老朋友，拉纳·米特（Rana Mitter），目前是牛津大学现代中国历史与政治教授，
but is about to head Harvardwards. So Oxford's loss is, well, the new Cambridge's gain. And author of two wonderful books on China's experience in the Second World War, China's War with Japan and China's Good War.. Dominic, we did those two incredibly harrowing and powerful episodes with Rana on China in the Second World War. Rana, welcome back to the show. The book that's probably more relevant to this is one that you wrote maybe 20 years ago, is it? A Better Revolution, China's Struggle with the Modern World. And I'm guessing you wrote that when it was less evident just how successful the process of China's transformation was. It was a very different China at that time, Tom. That's right. It's great to be back on with you and with Dominic. And I have to say,
但他即将前往哈佛。所以牛津的损失，就是新剑桥的收获。他还是两本关于中国在第二次世界大战中经历的精彩著作的作者，分别是《中国抗日战争》（China's War with Japan）和《中国的好战》（China's Good War）。多米尼克，我们和拉纳一起做了两期关于中国在二战中经历的令人心碎且震撼的节目。拉纳，欢迎回到节目。这本书可能与此更相关，是你大约20年前写的，对吧？《苦难的革命：中国与现代世界的斗争》（A Bitter Revolution, China's Struggle with the Modern World）。我猜你写这本书的时候，中国转型的成功过程还没有那么明显。那时候的中国非常不同，汤姆。没错。很高兴能再次和你以及多米尼克一起录节目。我必须说，
that book, A Bitter Revolution, China's Struggle with the Modern World, was written at a time when i had a bit more hair and my stomach was probably a little flatter loads of hair on oh there was even more than it's not gray of course if i were to time chinese top politburo leader i'd point out that might be because i had my own hair dye supplier since of course it's a sign of great virility amongst the chinese leadership that your hair must remain as black as possible for as long as possible to show that you've got it, you've still got it. The one exception, actually, interestingly, being Xi Jinping, who's led a little bit of
那本《苦难的革命：中国与现代世界的斗争》写于我头发还多一点、肚子可能平一点的时候。哦，头发很多。当然，如果我当时是中国的政治局高层，我会指出，这可能是因为我有自己的染发剂供应商，因为在中国领导层中，头发尽可能长时间保持乌黑是精力旺盛的标志，以显示你依然宝刀未老。唯一的一个例外，有趣的是，是习近平，他带了一点
gray show. And many people think we're doing the criminology of Beijing, that that shows that he's confident enough that he doesn't really need to do the hair dye shuffle. But I promise you, everything here is natural. But back at the start of the 21st century, the early 2000s, you're absolutely right. China itself was going through, and it might sound odd to say this, but it's very relevant to our discussion today about Deng Xiaoping and how contemporary China was made, that in some ways, it was a more liberal China. Now, it was the China that was just a decade or so out of Tiananmen
灰白。许多人认为我们是在对北京进行“发型学”研究，这表明他足够自信，不需要进行染发这种把戏。但我向你们保证，这里的一切都是自然的。但回到21世纪初，也就是2000年代初，你说得完全正确。中国本身正在经历——说出来可能听起来很奇怪，但这与我们今天关于邓小平以及当代中国是如何形成的讨论非常相关——在某些方面，那是一个更自由的中国。现在，那是距离天安门事件仅仅十年左右的中国，
Square, and I'm sure we'll talk about 1989 and that horrific year quite soon. But it was a time when it looked as if not, I think, that China was going to become a, might be trying out ideas that would essentially be judged on the idea of pragmatism rather than ideology. All of that seemed very possible in the early 2000s. And my book, A Bitter Revolution, looks back at an earlier period of Chinese history, the so-called May Fourth Movement, one of the great reform movements of the early 20th century, and tried to find the legacy of that more liberal China in the China of 20 years or so ago. As we may end up discussing, today's China does look much less liberal, much more constrained, much more buttoned down. So the real pivot that people often see in Chinese history runs from the end of the 1970s to Deng's retirement in the 1990s. So to put this into
我相信我们很快就会谈到1989年那个可怕的年份。但那是一个看起来中国似乎不会成为……可能正在尝试一些本质上会以实用主义而非意识形态来判断的想法的时期。在2000年代初，这一切似乎都非常有可能。我的书《苦难的革命》回顾了中国历史上的一个早期时期，即所谓的“五四运动”，这是20世纪初伟大的改革运动之一，并试图在20年前左右的中国找到那个更自由中国的遗产。正如我们最终可能会讨论的那样，今天的中国看起来确实不那么自由，受到更多限制，更加封闭。所以人们在中国历史中经常看到的真正转折点是从70年代末到邓小平90年代退休。所以为了把这一点放到
context for those of our listeners not super familiar with Chinese history, there'd been the Great Revolution at the end of the 1940s. There have been Mao's experiments, often very bloody experiments, the Great Leap Forward, the Cultural Revolution, and so on, which we've talked about with you. And then Mao dies in 1976. That's right, isn't it? And there is a power struggle to succeed him. So there's the gang of four involving his widow. There are other, perhaps more pragmatic sort of conservative figures in the party. There is this chap called Deng Xiaoping, who we're going to talk about, who is in, he's slightly in exile, isn't he, at this point? He's been brought back, but he's semi-detached.
背景中，对于那些不太熟悉中国历史的听众来说，40年代末发生了大革命。经历了毛泽东的实验，通常是非常血腥的实验，大跃进、文化大革命等等，我们已经和你讨论过了。然后毛泽东在1976年去世。没错，是这样吧？随后发生了一场继承他的权力斗争。有涉及他遗孀的“四人帮”。还有党内其他可能更务实、更保守的人物。有一个叫邓小平的家伙，我们要谈论他，他当时处于某种流放状态，不是吗？他被召回了，但处于半脱离状态。
So give us a sort of sense of the constellation of forces in the 1970s where Mao dies. Yes, the 1970s, Dominic, is an absolutely fascinating period. And actually, it's one of the ones that's of most interest today to historians who are trying to open up the next frontier of academic research on Chinese history. They call it the long 1970s because it starts really during the middle of the famous cultural revolution of the 1960s. And the three of us have talked about that on an earlier issue of edition of The Rest is History. And it goes probably somewhere actually into the early 1980s. There's a great new book actually forthcoming from
那么，请给我们讲讲毛泽东去世时70年代的势力格局。是的，70年代，多米尼克，是一个绝对迷人的时期。事实上，它是今天试图开启中国历史学术研究下一个前沿的史学家们最感兴趣的时期之一。他们称之为“漫长的70年代”，因为它实际上始于60年代著名的文化大革命中期。我们三个人在《历史的余味》之前的一期节目中谈到过这一点。它可能一直持续到80年代初。实际上，有一本很棒的新书即将出版，
the two historians, Chen Jian and Odd Arnavestad called The Great Transformation, which is exactly about this period. Briefly to say why it's important. It's essentially the moment when China tries a succession of economic as well as social experiments. And we're going to keep it as untechnical as possible, but economics will come into our discussion today because it's one of the things that reshapes not just China, but the world during this period. So essentially up to 19, let's say up to about 1966, the outbreak of the Cultural Revolution, China has what you might call a conventional Soviet style economy in many ways. It's command economy, top down. Stalin would have recognized it. That's not surprising because when Mao and his friends decided they were going to found a new economy,
由两位历史学家陈兼（Chen Jian）和奥德·阿恩·韦斯塔德（Odd Arne Westad）撰写，书名是《大转型》（The Great Transformation），正是关于这一时期的。简要说明一下为什么它很重要。这本质上是中国尝试一系列经济和社会实验的时刻。我们将尽量保持通俗易懂，但经济学将进入我们今天的讨论，因为它是这一时期重塑中国乃至世界的事情之一。所以基本上到1966年，也就是文化大革命爆发之前，中国在许多方面拥有你所说的苏联式传统经济。它是指令性经济，自上而下。斯大林会认出它来。这并不奇怪，因为当毛泽东和他的朋友们决定建立一种新经济时，
who better to consult than Joseph Stalin himself? We wrote a short textbook on economics. I'm sure it's the kind of thing which would today find a place only in a very, very small number of places, possibly North Korea or possibly a few UK senior commoners. But beyond that, it was important to Mao in terms of reshaping the economy Soviet style. Then in the 1960s to early 70s, the Cultural Revolution itself, the economy turns almost inwards. China really breaks off lots of its trade with the outside world it doesn't bring in uh outside ideas doesn't renew itself the intellectual property of china you might say is really run down because of course they've split up with the soviets in the early 1960s so the one source of technology which they have the soviet union is no longer talking to them and that brings us up to where you've started our story in the mid 1970s. Chairman Mao dies finally at the age of 83 in 1976, a pretty horrible death, actually, from AMS, Lou Gehrig's disease, as it's sometimes known.
还有谁比约瑟夫·斯大林本人更适合咨询呢？我们写了一本简短的经济学教科书。我相信这种东西在今天只会出现在极少数地方，可能是朝鲜，也可能是英国的少数几个高级教员休息室。但除此之外，它对毛泽东重塑苏联式经济很重要。然后在60年代到70年代初，文化大革命本身，经济几乎转向了内部。中国确实切断了与外部世界的许多贸易，不引入外部思想，不自我更新。中国的知识产权可以说因为60年代初与苏联的分裂而真正流失了，所以他们拥有的唯一技术来源——苏联——不再与他们交谈，这就把我们带到了你故事开始的70年代中期。毛主席终于在1976年以83岁高龄去世，实际上死得很惨，患的是肌萎缩侧索硬化症，也就是有时所说的卢·格里克病。
And the leadership is split between two factions. The hard left, sometimes known later known as the Gang of Four, including Mao's wife, but essentially four very radical left figures. And then a relatively more moderate faction. Prime Minister Zhou Enlai, who's probably the leader of that relatively moderate faction, just died a few months beforehand in April 1976. And in fact, his funeral leads to a demonstration by ordinary people who regard him as a decent figure in the leadership. But left behind, as you say, is Deng Xiaoping. These are figures who, of course, amongst other things, encouraged the visit of Richard Nixon to China. That had happened just four years before
领导层分裂为两个派系。极左派，后来被称为“四人帮”，包括毛泽东的妻子，本质上是四个非常激进的左翼人物。然后是一个相对温和的派系。总理周恩来，他可能是那个相对温和派系的领导人，就在几个月前的1976年4月去世了。事实上，他的葬礼引发了普通民众的示威，他们视他为领导层中一个正派的人物。但正如你所说，留下来的是邓小平。这些人当然在其他事情中鼓励了理查德·尼克松访问中国。那发生在仅仅四年前，
in 1972. So that American visit is also one of the signs of how a relatively more internationalist, more moderate faction was trying to make itself heard. But in 1976, when Mao died, the battle was not yet won. It was very much radicals versus reformers. And one of the things that Mao was worrying about in his final years and months was that the fate of Stalin would be visited on him. Stalin was posthumously condemned. Mao, in the end, is not condemned, is he? So is there a sense in which the faction fight is not just to seize the commanding heights of China, but to present themselves as the authentic heirs of Mao? from Deng Xiaoping's statement. He's too big a figure simply to throw out the revolutionary pantheon. He's Lenin and Stalin and all the other major figures of the Soviet revolution,
1972年。所以那次美国访问也是一个迹象，表明一个相对更国际化、更温和的派系正试图发出自己的声音。但在1976年毛泽东去世时，战斗尚未结束。这很大程度上是激进派与改革派之间的较量。毛泽东在最后几年和几个月里担心的一件事是，斯大林的命运会降临到他身上。斯大林在死后受到了谴责。毛泽东最终没有被谴责，对吧？那么，派系斗争是否不仅仅是为了夺取中国的最高权力，而是为了把自己表现为毛泽东的正统继承人？从邓小平的声明来看。他是一个太重要的人物，不能简单地从革命先贤祠中剔除。他是列宁、斯大林和苏联革命中所有其他主要人物的结合体，
the Bolshevik revolution, combined together in one person. But having said that, a few years later, just to fast forward for a moment to 1981, there is an official resolution of the party, which does say that the Cultural Revolution, which is Mao's own personal invention and decision, is a disaster to be condemned. And that is essentially a pretty clear statement that the party was repudiating one of his major policy decisions. But there's still a turmoil in 1976-77, because we think of this as the era of Deng Xiaoping. We've mentioned his name, we're going to talk a lot about him. But it's worth remembering that Deng Xiaoping was not the man who took over at this time. The man who Mao essentially tapped on the shoulder, you know,
布尔什维克革命，集于一身。但话虽如此，几年后，让我们快进到1981年，党有一个正式决议，确实说文化大革命——这是毛泽东个人的发明和决定——是一场灾难，应该受到谴责。这本质上是一个非常明确的声明，表明党否定了他的一项重大政策决定。但1976-77年仍然处于动荡之中，因为我们认为这是邓小平时代。我们提到了他的名字，我们将谈论很多关于他的事情。但值得记住的是，邓小平并不是当时接管权力的人。毛泽东基本上在临终前，你知道，几乎是字面意思上拍了拍肩膀的人，是一个几乎被遗忘的人物，叫华国锋。他实际上是毛泽东之后唯一拥有“主席”头衔的人，所以从毛主席，他们变成了华主席。现在一方面，他是一个公开说他将遵循毛泽东所有政策的人，他被称为“两个凡是”，理由是凡是毛泽东提出的，我们都将遵循。但实际上他并不傻。而且在掌权后非常非常快地，他发动了对“四人帮”和极左派的清洗。而华国锋而不是“四人帮”被毛泽东明确拍了肩膀的原因是，毛泽东本人担心他的遗产……但他同时也务实地意识到，那些实际上支持最激进政策的人可能无法维持权力，最终会在自身矛盾的重压下倒台。他们会崩溃。出于这个原因，他最后最后的一个举动是拍了一个更务实的人，也就是
pretty much almost literally from his deathbed, was an almost forgotten figure called Hua Guofeng. He was in fact the only other person after Mao to have the title chairman so from chairman Mao they went to chairman Hua now on the one hand he was someone who openly said that he would follow all of the policies of Mao he was nicknamed the whateverist on the grounds that whatever Mao has put forward we will we will follow but actually he was no fool. And very, very quickly afterwards, after coming to power, he launched a purge against the Gang of Four and the hard left. And the reason that Hua Guofeng and not the Gang of Four were clearly tapped on the shoulder by Mao was that Mao himself was worried that his legacy of But he was also pragmatic enough to realize that the people who actually were behind the most radical policies probably could not sustain power, and in the end would fall under the weight of their own contradictions. They would collapse. For that reason, his very, very last act was to tap someone a bit more pragmatic in the shape
华国锋。这就是为什么中国政治的轨迹开始向更温和的方向移动。所以他给华国锋写了几行字，毛泽东写道：慢慢来，不要着急，按过去方针办。他确实写了。他加了另一行，或者被认为嘟囔了那行字，我在牛津学院做行政决定时经常用，意思是，如果你负责做这件事，我对此感到放心。我对此没问题。在这种情况下，他指的——我必须补充说，这和我在这里做这件事时的意思不同——是你现在需要出去逮捕一大批遵循错误政策的人。换句话说，他基本上是在给华国锋祝福，让他和各种人，
of Hua Guofeng. That's why the trajectory of Chinese politics began to move in a more moderate direction. So he gives, he scrawls a few lines on a scrap of paper, Mao does, to Hua Guofeng, go slowly, don't rush, act according to past directions. He did. He added another line, or was supposed to sort of mutter the line, which I quite often use when making administrative decisions in the college here in Oxford, which is, which means, if you're in charge of doing this, I'm at ease with it. I'm fine with it. And what he meant by that in this case, which I hasten to add is not what I mean when I'm doing this in my college, is you need to go out now and arrest a whole bunch of people who are following the wrong policy. In other words, he was basically giving the blessing to Hua Wufeng that he, along with various people,
一个叫汪东兴的人，他本质上是高层领导中安全机构的负责人，应该去发动中国历史的下一个阶段，这将涉及罢免和逮捕“四人帮”，并转向一套相对
a man named Wang Gengxin, who was essentially head of the security apparatus amongst the top leadership, should go and essentially launch the next phase of Chinese history, which would involve the deposing and arrest of the Gang of Four, and the move instead to a relatively
更温和的政策，这将很快导致邓小平的崛起。好吧，既然你提到了他，让我们把他带到舞台中心。所以邓小平，他已经……我的意思是，他已经是一个相当老的人了。我的意思是，这是一个相当老人政治的体制，不是吗？他一直都在那里。他出生在四川，他在所有关键时刻都在那里。我想，拉纳，他经常在毛泽东身边，对吧？请给我们讲讲他的个性和背景以及他到目前为止的记录，因为这是一个迷人的故事。
more moderate set of policies, which would quite soon lead to the rise of Deng Xiaoping. Well, now that you've mentioned him, let's bring him onto the center stage. So Deng Xiaoping, he has been, I mean, he's already quite an old man. I mean, this is quite a gerontocratic system, isn't it? And he has been there. He's born in Sichuan and he's been there at all the key moments. Often at mouse side, I think, Rana, that's right, isn't it? Give us some sense of him as a personality and his background and his record up to this point, because it's a fascinating story.
好吧，首先，多米尼克，用数字来说，他在1977年，当这个故事真正开始起飞时，他已经73岁了。所以相比之下，比如说，美国总统，他只是一个年轻人，可以这么说。但尽管他73岁了，就像美国总统一样，他似乎没有失去任何精力。他出生在四川省。现在，许多人至少因为那个地区出产的美味火辣的食物而知道四川。但值得注意的是，它也是一个以政治火辣而闻名的地区。它一直是中国相当激进的一部分。它在遥远的西南方。
Well, first of all, Dominic, to put numbers on it, he was, well, in 1977, when this, 76, 77, when this story really begins to take off, he was 73 years old. So compared, let's say, to the President of the United States, he was just a stripling, it's fair to say. But although he was 73 years old, rather like the President of the United States, he appeared to have lost none of his energy. He'd been born in Sichuan province. Now, many people will know Sichuan by name, at least because of the fantastic fiery food that comes from that area. But it's worth noting that it's also an area that's known for the fieriness of its politics. It's always been quite a radical part of China. It's down in the far southwest.
它一直与东部沿海或东部地区的大城市（北京、南京等）有点隔绝，这让人们在那里可以按照自己的方式进行政治和社会活动。邓小平并非出生于贫困。他出生在一个广义上的农民家庭，但那是一个相当富裕的农民家庭。我想他家的房子有17个房间。我不知道你们住什么样的豪宅，但我必须说，如果我有17个房间，我会过得非常好。我想要17个房间。是的，确实。我想，公平地说，20世纪初中国的抵押贷款利率可能比21世纪末的英国更合理。
And it's always been a bit separated from the big capital cities of the eastern seaboard or eastern region, Beijing, Nanjing and so forth, which has let people get on a bit with their own type of politics and society there. Deng Xiaoping was not born into poverty. He was born into a peasant family in a broad sense, but it was quite a rich peasant family. I think his family house had 17 rooms. I don't know what kind of mansions you guys live in, but I have to say, if I had 17 rooms, I'd be doing extremely well. I'd love 17 rooms. Yes, indeed. I think, to be fair, probably the mortgage rates in early 20th century China were more reasonable than they are in late 21st century Britain.
但他基本上发现自己处于这种传统的富农背景中。事实上，他接受了教育，既学习了不少中国经典，也学习了当时正在变得非常普遍的新现代学科。记住，他出生的那一年，1904年，正是中国清朝（最后一个朝代）最终废除传统科举考试的那一年，科举考试大约一千年来一直被视为进入官僚体系的门户。一千年后，整个体系基本上被一笔勾销了。所以邓小平确实出生在下一代学生的第一代中，他们将学习现代研究、语言、
But he basically found himself as part of this traditional rich peasant background. And actually, he got an education learning both quite a bit of the Chinese classics, but also the new modern subjects that were becoming very widespread. Remember, the year that he was born, 1904, was exactly the same year that China's Qing dynasty, the last dynasty, finally abolished the traditional imperial exams, which for about a thousand years had been taken as the gateway to rising up in the bureaucracy. And after a thousand years, that whole system was basically swept away with the stroke of a pen. So Deng Xiaoping is literally born in the first generation of students who were in the next generation who would study modern studies, languages,
科学等等。而且他受到启发，实际上在1920年就前往法国，参加了一个勤工俭学项目。他对激进政治变得非常感兴趣，当时这种政治在中国大部分地区也非常盛行。1921年是中共的成立年份。所以这一切都发生在那个时候。他学法语吗？
science, and so forth. And he was inspired enough, actually, by 1920 to head out to France, where he took part in a work-study program. He became very interested in radical politics, which was also buzzing in a big way in much of China at that time. Bearingham in 1921 is the founding year of the Chinese Communist Party. So it's all happening at this time. Does he learn French?
学得不太好。学得不太好。他尝试过，但最终，邓小平有很多技能也有很多缺陷，但学习外语并不是他的强项。他在法国期间确实培养了对羊角面包的深厚热爱。哦，真的吗？
Not very well. Not very well. He has a go, but in the end, Deng Xiaoping had many skills as well as many flaws, but learning foreign languages wasn't really one of them. He did, while he was in France, develop a deep love for croissant. Oh, did he?
而且必须说，快进一下，当他在70年代和80年代作为最高领导人回到欧洲时，他确保羊角面包的供应重新开始，这样他就可以继续享用它们。所以他确实从法国人那里学到了一些东西。他还了解了他所看到的欧洲普通工人的可怕状况。这进一步激励他，在共产党和共产国际的影响下，发展他的知识。所以他最终去了，我想，
And it has to be said, fast forwarding just for a moment, when he finally gets back to Europe as top leader in the 70s and 80s, he makes sure that the croissant supply is restarted so that he can keep up with those. So he does learn something from the French. He also learns about what he saw as the horrific conditions of ordinary workers in Europe. And this inspires him yet further, again, under Communist Party and Comintern influence, to develop his knowledge. So he ends up at, I think,
大学历史上名字最宏伟的大学，位于莫斯科的东方劳动者共产主义大学。我的意思是，这是一个很棒的名字。正如有人指出的，我想实际上是历史学家菲利普·斯诺，如果你称它为东方劳动者中央大学，你可以把它缩写为CUTE（可爱）。所以他参加了CUTE。我必须说，那不是一个非常可爱的地方，相当强硬。但所有这些意味着海外经历，毛泽东当然从未有过，毛泽东一生只去过两次海外，都是去访问斯大林。他阅读广泛，但他从未去过法国，从未去过英国。所以邓小平有那种欧洲经历。但他也在20年代在莫斯科真正以一种强硬的方式学习马克思主义。这把他带回了中国。然后在那一点上，他成为非凡的地下共产主义运动的一部分。他在1930年代，1934年到1935年参加了长征，
the university with the most magnificent name in the history of universities, the Moscow-based University of the Toilers of the East. I mean, it's a great name. As someone pointed out, I think it was actually historian Philip Snow, if you call it the central university
那次旅程意味着在当时蒋介石领导的国民党政府的迫害下，他们被迫向中国内地进军。记住，这就是真正筛选出共产主义革命运动最核心、最坚硬部分的“长征”。那些幸存下来的人，你知道，在内陆中国行军数千英里，在革命等级制度中确实是最纯粹的。然后他基本上成为该运动的一部分。他是一位主要的军事人物。人们经常忘记，他在40年代末反对国民党的内战中实际上是一位有相当技巧的军事战略家。
of the Toilers of the East, you can abbreviate it to CUTE. So he attended CUTE. It wasn't a very cute place, I have to say, pretty hard line. But all of this meant that overseas experience, which Mao never had, of course, Mao only ever traveled overseas twice to visit Stalin as it happened. He read widely, but he never went to France, never went to Britain. So Deng had that European experience. But he also found himself really learning Marxism in a hardcore sort of way in Moscow in the 1920s. That brings him back to China. And then at that point, he becomes part of the extraordinary underground communist movement. He was on the Long March in the 1930s, 1934 to 1935,
毛泽东当然在1949年与他的共产主义盟友、他的共产主义同志一起征服了大陆。在此后的几年里，邓小平在毛泽东掌权期间是他非常非常得力的助手。这让你了解后来发生了什么。在50年代，当他们进行土地改革时，这基本上是土地的重新分配和对中国许多数十万地主的残酷杀戮。毛泽东在50年代不得不告诉邓小平停止杀那么多人，因为他杀得太多了。所以认为毛泽东是一个相比邓小平极其暴力的人物，如果你看更广泛的轨迹，故事有点不同。然后最后，带入文化大革命时期，邓小平的60年代，
that journey that meant that under essentially persecution from the nationalist government of China at the time under Chiang Kai-shek, they're forced to march to the interior of China. Remember, this is the long march that really sorts the absolute hardcore diamond hard center of the communist revolutionary movement. The people who survive that, you know, thousands and thousands of miles of marching through internal China are really the purest of the pure in terms of the revolutionary hierarchy. And then he essentially becomes part of that movement. He is a major military figure. It's often forgotten he was actually a military strategist of some skill in the civil war against the nationalists in the late 1940s.
带我们到毛泽东去世，是一个起起落落的时期。他起初是文化大革命的绝对强硬支持者。他是什么异见人士的想法从来都不是真的。但他受到怀疑，因为在60年代初，他曾与另一位最高领导人刘少奇一起，在大跃进（1958年至62年）的灾难之后，在中国恢复了一种有限的资本主义形式，这是一场由极其误判且坦率地说是妄想的关于种植粮食的经济政策引起的恐怖饥荒，导致了可怕的后果，饿死了数千万农民。所以邓小平和刘少奇在这一点上成为了温和派，有点像20年代列宁的新经济政策。他们引入了一点资本主义。它确实恢复了经济，但毛泽东从未完全原谅他放弃了社会主义。所以当文化大革命中期到来时，邓小平受到毛泽东的迫害。他的儿子邓朴方被红卫兵抓获，从窗户扔出，终身残疾，
Mao, of course, conquers the mainland along with his communist allies, his communist comrades in 1949. In the years following that, Deng is a big, big right-hand man to Mao in terms of his period in power. This gives you an indication of what happens later. In the 1950s, as they undertake land reform, which is basically the redistribution of land and the brutal killing of many hundreds of thousands of landlords in China. Mao has to tell Deng Xiaoping in the 1950s to stop killing so many people because he's killing so many. So the idea that Mao is this sort of supremely violent character compared to Deng, the story's a bit different if you look at the wider trajectory. And then finally, taking it through the Cultural Revolution period, Deng's 1960s,
余生都在轮椅上度过。邓小平成为不受欢迎的人，基本上在文化大革命中期被从领导层中清洗出去。他在70年代初短暂回归，但在1976年再次被清洗。所以他是一个非常绝对的中国共产党仆人。人们常说，他表现出的唯一情感，他在最深层次上表现出的唯一真正的爱，是为革命，而不是为他的家人。但与此同时，他是一个愿意实验、愿意以毛泽东在某种程度上并不具备的方式务实的人。所以是一个非常神秘的人物。但拉纳，大概毛泽东的去世，
taking us up to the death of Mao, is a period of up and down. He is, at the beginning, an absolutely hardline supporter of the Cultural Revolution. The idea that he was some sort of dissenter was never the case. But he was under suspicion because in the early 1960s, he had been involved, along with another top leader, Liu Shaoqi, in bringing back a form of limited capitalism to China after the disaster of the Great Leap Forward, 1958 to 62, a horrific famine caused by a deeply misjudged and frankly delusional economic policy about growing grain that had gone horribly wrong and starved tens of millions of peasants to death. So Deng Xiaoping and Liu Shaoqi become the moderates at this point, a little like Lenin with the new economic policy of the 20s. They bring in a bit more capitalism. It does revive the economy, but Mao never entirely forgave him for having abandoned socialism. And so when it comes to the middle of the Cultural Revolution, Deng Xiaoping is persecuted by Mao. His son, Deng Pufang, is famously captured by red guards and thrown out of a window and crippled
即使你不亲自谴责毛泽东，也确实提供了实验的空间，因为你可以责怪那些被清洗的人，把他们描绘成相当于国王的邪恶顾问。所以你可以通过说“毛泽东本来会想这样做”来做与毛泽东不同的事情。是“四人帮”或其他什么人阻止了我们这样做。绝对正确。如果你想想多米尼克在对话开始时读到的邓小平的那段长文，其中有一个特别的短语让我印象深刻，正如你所说的那样，那就是“反对本本主义”。现在，这是毛泽东最著名的文章之一《反对本本主义》的直接翻译。所以换句话说，反对那种认为你可以从书本中学习你需要知道的一切的想法。这在邓小平作为宣传手段方面是天才，
for life. He's in a wheelchair for the rest of his life. And Deng Xiaoping becomes a persona non grata, essentially purged from the leadership by the midpoint of the Cultural Revolution. He's briefly brought back in the early 1970s, but then is purged again in 1976. And so he's a figure who is very much an absolute servant of the Chinese Communist Party. It's often said that the only emotion he ever showed, the only real love he showed at the most deep level was for the revolution, not for his family. But at the same time, someone willing to experiment, willing to be pragmatic in a way that Mao really wasn't in quite the same sort of way. So a deeply enigmatic character. But Rana, presumably the death of Mao,
因为它所做的是采用了毛泽东最著名的名言之一。所以你不能以任何方式反对那个声明的等级制度或起源。但邓小平正在以一种非常不同的方式使用它。当他说你不能只是有本本主义时，毛泽东几乎意味着你必须放弃书本的想法，
even if you're not condemning Mao personally, does offer scope for experimentation because you can blame the people who've been purged and cast them as the equivalent of the king's evil advisors. So you can do things differently to Mao by saying, Mao would have wanted to do this. It was the gang of four, whoever, whatever, who prevented us from doing it. Absolutely right. And if you think about the long piece from Dung that Dominic read out at the beginning of the conversation, there's one particular phrase in there that struck me, as you said it, which is the phrase,
因为文化大革命显然是关于被阅读而不是成为专家。相反，邓小平的意思是实际上你必须务实。你不能仅仅阅读，例如，马克思列宁主义的书籍，并期望你会知道从中产生的一切。相反，也许你需要书，但它们必须是关于科学、技术、外语的书。或者经济学。或者经济学，绝对。这就是他可以不断地采用毛泽东的名言，
oppose book worship. Now, this is a direct translation of one of Mao's most famous essays, Fundui Bundundun,, literally oppose bookism. So in other words, oppose the idea that you can learn everything you need to know from books. And this is brilliant on Deng Xiaoping's part as a piece of propaganda,
并将它们转向一种非常不同的共产主义，他当然会与此联系在一起。他是如何从边缘人物，刚刚再次被清洗，到克服华国锋并成为最高领导人的？所以，我的意思是，从毛泽东去世到我在开头读到的那篇演讲（那是1978年）之间只有两年。所以这个一直作为仆人的人是如何成为主人的？在1975年到1977年之间，你看到了全球政治或现代史上发生的最令人震惊的转变之一，我会说，那就是邓小平从一个基本上被他的政治敌人、被“四人帮”、极左派、毛夫人江青和其他三个人扔进……好吧，不是黑暗之外，但肯定是中国农村的遥远
because what it does is take one of Mao's most famous sayings. So you couldn't, you know, in any way stand against the hierarchy of that or the origins of that particular statement. But Deng is using it in a very different way. When he says you can't just have book worship, Mao almost meant that you had to sort of abandon the idea of books altogether
地方的人，变成了一个基本上是全中国统治者的人。本质上，它来自临时领导人华国锋（他当然不认为自己是临时领导人，但很快就变成了这样）和邓小平更广泛的联系之间发生的一种奇怪的动态。因为本质上，华国锋做了邓小平和领导层中其他温和派需要他做的事情，那就是摆脱最激进的元素，即“四人帮”的文化大革命元素。但随后邓小平开始利用他在中国共产党内非常非常深的关系网，
because the Cultural Revolution obviously was about being read rather than being expert. Instead, what Deng Xiaoping means is that actually you have to be pragmatic. You can't just read, for instance, books of Marxism-Leninism and expect you will know everything that comes from those. Instead, maybe you need books, but they have to be books. You can't just read, for instance, books of Marxism-Leninism and expect you will know everything that comes from those. Instead, maybe you need books, but they have to be books about science, technology, foreign languages. Or economics. Or economics, absolutely. And that is the way in which he could constantly take Mao's sayings
来真正开始让华国锋下台。军队是邓小平拥有的联系点之一，但这只是其中之一。所以记住我之前简要说过，邓小平实际上是1946年到1949年内战中一位出色的军事指挥官，这给了他信誉。正如我们从我们自己的社会中知道的那样，
and turn them towards a very different sort of communism that he would, of course, be associated with. How does he go from being on the fringes, having just been purged yet again, to overcoming Hua and becoming the paramount leader? So, I mean, there's only two years between Mao's death and that speech that I read out at the beginning, which was 1978. So how does this person who's always been a servant become the master? Between 1975 and 1977, you see one of the most astonishing turnarounds that has ever happened in global politics or modern history, I would say, and that is Deng Xiaoping moving from being essentially a man who has been cast into, well, not out of darkness, but certainly the far
当一个人在战略和战斗中确实有深刻而重要的经验，并且确实在前线冒过生命危险时，他们会被武装部队认真对待。去那些军事领导人那里说，看，实际上我认为我们需要继续前进，这在能够向华国锋这样的人施压方面非常有力，他并没有完全来自那种背景。此外，我的意思是，中国共产党是许多东西。但我认为在其整个世纪的存在过程中，你必须把它看作一个网络。在这个意义上，它与，哦，我不知道，英国政客去牛津，比如说，你知道，换句话说，一套理解，一种人类学，
reaches of the Chinese countryside by his political enemies, by the Gang of Four, the radical left, Madame Mao, Jiang Qing, and the other three, to someone who essentially is the ruler of all China. And essentially, it comes from a strange sort of dynamic that happens between the interim leader, Hua Guofeng, who of course didn't think of himself as the interim leader, but rapidly became so, and Deng Xiaoping's wider connections. Because essentially, Hua Guofeng did what Deng and the other moderates in the leadership needed him to do, which was to get rid of the most radical elements, the Cultural Revolution elements of the Gang of Four. But then Deng started to use his very, very deep web of connection within the Chinese Communist Party
超越了纸上的东西。在这种情况下，当然有许多人是中国共产党的成员，数以百万计，真的，但只有极少数像邓小平那样拥有与苏联的长期联系，与其他在日本人或国民党空袭下颤抖的同志们有联系。换句话说，有那种被社会化为革命者意味着什么的经验。事实证明，这在1975、76、77年邓小平寻求再次崛起时，是一套非常强大的杠杆。本质上，发生的事情是，华国锋因为毛泽东拍了他的肩膀而进入了最高领导层，一旦毛泽东去世，发现实际上邓小平的人都在他周围。他被那些不在他这边的人包围了。
to actually start to ease Hua out of office. The army was one of the points of connection that Deng had, but it was just one. So remember I said briefly before that Deng Xiaoping was actually a brilliant military commander in the Civil War of 1946 to 1949, and that gave him credibility. Someone who was actually, we know from our own societies,
在某些方面，非常明智地，不像我们可以点名的某些最高领导人，他决定谨慎是勇气的更好部分。他基本上退后了一步，不是完全自愿的，但相当和平。他没有试图发动反政变。而且实际上它得到了回报，因为邓小平——这又是政治至少会改变一段时间的迹象——没有杀他，没有清洗他，没有逮捕他，没有把他送到农村，给了他一个不错的闲职。而且实际上，一直到21世纪初，他都活得很好。他过去常来政治局，基本上坐在后面打个盹。他被允许进入温和的退休状态，这并不是
when someone has actually had deep and important experience in strategy and combat and has actually risked their own lives on the front line they are taken seriously by the armed forces and going to those military leaders and saying look actually i think we need to move on was very powerful in terms of being able to pressure someone like hua guo feng who didn't quite come from that sort of background in addition i mean I mean, the Chinese Communist Party is many things. But I think over the course of its entire century of existence, you have to think of it as a network. In that sense, it's no different from, oh, I don't know, British politicians going to Oxford, let's say, you know, in other words, a set of understandings, a sort of anthropology
中国共产党领导人在过去50年里真正允许发生的事情。所以这也是邓小平方面的一个迹象，他会在获取权力方面无情，但他不会对权力的受害者无情，只要他们遵守游戏规则。好吧，那太棒了，拉纳。所以邓小平现在基本上是中国的主人。在下半部分，我们将看到他如何利用他的权力。也许这是《历史的余味》第一次出现Wham（威猛乐队）。所以我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈
that goes beyond just what's on a piece of paper. And in this case, of course, there are many people who were members of the Chinese Communist Party, millions and millions of them, really, but only very few like Deng Xiaoping have had the long-standing connections with the Soviet Union, with other comrades who had shivered, you know, in being sort of air-raid by the Japanese or by the nationalists. In other words, have the kind of experience of being socialized into what it meant to be a revolutionary. And that proved to be a very powerful set of levers to pull in 1975, 76, 77, when Deng was looking to rise to the top again. Essentially, what happened was that Hua Guofeng, having got to the top leadership because Mao had tapped him on the shoulder, once Mao had died, found that actually Deng Xiaoping's people were all around him. He was surrounded by people who weren't on his side.
八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在审视中国的开放，中国从毛泽东时代以来的恢复。我们特别关注邓小平，这位极其果断的人物，在前半部分，我们的嘉宾拉纳·米特描述了他如何有效地成为中国的统治者。拉纳，邓小平用他拥有的这种权力做了什么？
And in some ways, very wisely, unlike some of the top leaders we could name, he decided that discretion would be a better part of valor. He essentially stepped back, not entirely willingly, but fairly peacefully. He didn't try and launch a counter coup. And actually, it paid off because Deng Xiaoping, and again, it was a sign of how politics was going to change at least for a while, didn't kill him, didn't purge him, didn't arrest him, didn't send him out to the countryside, gave him a nice sort of sinecure job. And actually, all the way into the early 2000s, he was alive and well. He used to come to the Politburo, basically sit at the back and have a bit of a nap. And he was allowed to go into a gentle retirement, which is not something that
在某些方面，他非常明智地决定——不像我们能点名的某些高层领导人那样——审慎才是勇气的最好部分。他基本上退居二线，虽然并非完全出于自愿，但相当和平。他没有试图发动反政变。事实上，这得到了回报，因为邓小平——这再次表明了政治至少在一段时间内将如何改变——没有杀他，没有清洗他，没有逮捕他，也没有把他下放到农村，而是给了他一份不错的闲职。实际上，直到21世纪初，他都活得好好的。他过去常去政治局，基本上坐在后面打个盹。他被允许安享晚年，这在过去50年里并不是中国共产党领导人真正允许发生的事情。
Chinese communist leaders had really allowed to happen during the previous 50 years. So it was also a sign on Deng Xiaoping's part that he would be ruthless about getting power, but he would not be ruthless with the victims of his power as long as they played the game. Okay, well, that's brilliant, Rana. So Deng is now essentially the ruler of China. And in the second half, we will see what he does with his power. And maybe for the first time on The Rest Is History, Wham will feature. So we'll be back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz
因此，这也表明邓小平在夺取权力时会毫不留情，但只要对方遵守游戏规则，他就不会对权力的受害者赶尽杀绝。好的，拉娜，这太精彩了。所以邓现在基本上是中国的主宰了。在下半部分，我们将看看他如何运用自己的权力。也许这是《历史的余味》第一次出现威猛乐队（Wham）。我们几分钟后回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。
gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the opening of China, the recovery of China from the time of Mao. And we are looking at Deng Xiaoping in particular, this incredibly decisive figure who in the first half, our guest Rana Mitter described how he effectively became the ruler of China. And Rana, what does Deng do with this power that he has
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后真相，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在审视中国的开放，中国从毛泽东时代以来的复苏。我们特别关注邓小平，这位极其果断的人物，在前半部分，我们的嘉宾拉娜·米特描述了他如何有效地成为了中国的主宰。拉娜，邓是如何运用他所拥有的权力的呢？
accrued? Put it in its most simple, Tom. Deng Xiaoping used the power that took him to become China's paramount leader, really essentially from 1977-78 onwards, to undertake the population of China, of course, to essentially turn it from being a socialist command economy to becoming a country that combined the authoritarian top-down politics of a socialist country with a remarkable experiment in actually very free market capitalism. And in doing that, as it turned out, because of course, it's an experiment they could have known at the time, they launched one of the biggest economic booms that has ever been seen in history and set China on the path to where it is today, the world's second biggest economy, with at least some chance potentially of becoming the biggest in the world in the next 10 years or so. So that was really the path that Deng Xiaoping set China on.
积累？汤姆，用最简单的话来说。邓小平利用他成为中国最高领导人的权力，实际上是从1977-78年开始，去领导中国，当然，本质上是将中国从社会主义指令性经济转变为一个既有社会主义国家自上而下的威权政治，又有一个真正非常自由的市场资本主义的非凡实验的国家。在这样做的过程中，事实证明，因为这当然是一个他们当时可能知道的实验，他们发动了历史上见过的最大的经济繁荣之一，并使中国走上了今天的道路，成为世界第二大经济体，在未来10年左右至少有可能成为世界第一大经济体。所以这确实是邓小平为中国设定的道路。
We did a podcast about Mikhail Gorbachev, and we were talking in that about how much Gorbachev was influenced by Lenin and his belief that you had to get back to the original principles of the revolution. He had volumes of Lenin by his bedside, all this kind of thing. How much is Deng doing the same thing? Because obviously there's some similarities with Lenin's new economic policy or perceived similarities. How much is he trying to get back to what he sees as an original sort of authentic spirit of true communism without the corruption and the feuding and the factionalism of the intervening decades? Deng Xiaoping, I think, is trying to do two things simultaneously during this period. One is to make sure that the absolute rule of the Chinese Communist Party is not in any way challenged. So any idea that he was trying to move China towards
我们做过一期关于米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫的播客，我们在那期节目中谈到了戈尔巴乔夫在多大程度上受到列宁的影响，以及他认为必须回归革命原始原则的信念。他的床头放着列宁的著作，诸如此类。邓小平在多大程度上也在做同样的事情？因为显然这与列宁的新经济政策有一些相似之处，或者说是人们认为的相似之处。他在多大程度上试图回归他所认为的真正共产主义的原始精神，而不受过去几十年腐败、内斗和派系主义的影响？我认为，邓小平在这一时期试图同时做两件事。一是确保中国共产党的绝对统治地位不受任何挑战。所以任何认为他试图将中国推向
a more liberal, pluralist, democratic system in the sense that you get in Germany or Japan or somewhere like that is not the case. But I think that he was much, much more pragmatic when it came to the idea of what economics might mean. And first of all, he was always very frank, at least in the conversations that have been transcribed that have come to us, that he himself did not claim to be an economic expert. You know, he left it to others. He knew what was going on.
一个更自由、多元、民主的体系，就像你在德国或日本或其他地方看到的那样，是不可能的。但我认为，在经济意味着什么这个问题上，他要务实得多。首先，他总是非常坦率，至少在传给我们的谈话记录中是这样，他自己并不声称是经济专家。你知道，他把这些留给了别人。他知道发生了什么。
And I think actually you can see the range of economic thinking that influenced Deng and the other top leaders during this period by the range of people who were invited to come and talk about it. And the best source for this is the fantastic book Unlikely Partners by Julian DeWertz, who is a historian who has looked at the different economic models that Deng and also his fellow Politburo members, such as Charles Young, experimented with. So yes, they did look a great deal at what socialist economics might mean, but they invited Milton Friedman to visit China. And actually, I have to say that what he said to the party school, the Communist Party school, was so outrageous from their point of view that they actually marched to his hotel room and besieged him and Rose Friedman there and kind of read them a lecture on socialist economics and what it meant.
而且我认为，实际上你可以通过受邀来谈论这一问题的各类人士，看出影响邓小平和这一时期其他最高领导人的经济思想范围。最好的来源是朱利安·德沃茨（Julian DeWertz）那本精彩的著作《不太可能的伙伴》（Unlikely Partners），他是一位历史学家，研究了邓小平和他的政治局同事（如陈云）所尝试的不同经济模式。所以是的，他们确实对社会主义经济可能意味着什么进行了大量的研究，但他们邀请了米尔顿·弗里德曼（Milton Friedman）访问中国。而且实际上，我不得不说，他对比党校（中共中央党校）所说的话，从他们的角度来看是如此令人愤慨，以至于他们实际上游行到他的酒店房间，围攻他和罗斯·弗里德曼（Rose Friedman），并给他们上了一堂关于社会主义经济及其含义的课。
Also, British social democratic figures like Alec Cairncross were invited as well. But probably the most influential figure, or at least amongst the most influential figures, were the ones who are a bit forgotten now, who were the people who were trying to reform Eastern European communist economics, people like Janusz Kornai from Hungary. You might remember there was a phrase in the late Cold War, goulash communism, which was very much about trying to combine aspects of market economics with a continued communist authority. Because, of course, at that point, people still didn't realize that 1989 would mean the fall of the Berlin Wall and the complete
此外，英国社会民主党人士如亚历克·凯恩克罗斯（Alec Cairncross）也受到了邀请。但可能最有影响力的人物，或者至少是最有影响力的人物之一，是现在有点被遗忘的人，即那些试图改革东欧共产主义经济的人，比如匈牙利的亚诺什·科尔奈（Janusz Kornai）。你可能还记得冷战后期有一个词叫“古拉什共产主义”（goulash communism），它非常强调试图将市场经济的各个方面与持续的共产主义权威结合起来。因为当然，在那个时候，人们仍然没有意识到1989年将意味着柏林墙的倒塌和那个体系的彻底
destruction of that system. So the Chinese, don't forget, in the late Cold War, were playing with a system where they could look at America, fairly capitalist and red in tooth and claw, a Soviet Union, which they knew perfectly well, seemed to be decaying in all sorts of ways, even while Gorbachev was trying to revive it. And that sort of middle way, which for them was a sort of Eastern European reformist communism. And that, I think, is the set of mixtures that Deng Xiaoping and those around him were trying to juggle and balance. Tom said right at the beginning of the show, we're looking at where this comes from,
毁灭。所以别忘了，中国在冷战后期是在玩弄一个体系，他们可以看看美国，相当资本主义且残酷无情；看看苏联，他们非常清楚，即使在戈尔巴乔夫试图复兴它的时候，它似乎也在各方面衰落。而那种中间道路，对他们来说是一种东欧改良主义的共产主义。我认为，这就是邓小平和周围的人试图权衡和平衡的混合体。汤姆在节目一开始就说，我们正在研究这一切的来源，
how much it's rooted in Chinese deep history. Is Deng conscious of being the heir to a pre-communist past, first of all? Or is he still completely trapped by the communist way of thinking, that the revolution was kind of year zero, as it were? And secondly, how much are they conscious of China being this vast reservoir of untapped potential, which is obviously not the case, you know, even when you're looking at a country that turns out to be reasonably successful like Hungary or Poland or somewhere in China is a completely different order.
它在多大程度上植根于中国深厚的历史。首先，邓小平是否意识到自己是前共产主义过去的继承人？还是他仍然完全被共产主义的思维方式所困，认为革命就像是零年？其次，他们有多大程度上意识到中国是一个巨大的未开发潜力库，这显然不是事实，你知道，即使当你看到一个像匈牙利或波兰这样相当成功的国家时，中国的情况也完全是另一个量级。
So how much is he conscious of that? He's very conscious of it because one of the things that we know was happening even in the last years of the cultural revolution was economic experimentation with new markets, but also new incentives for the labor force. And there is a combination here, as it turns out for China, a very helpful one of changes in state direction in terms of what the markets are allowed to do and what has to be handed over under the state command economy. And also the incentives given to peasants, to workers, to small enterprises, in terms of being able to create a new sort of private sector driven economy
那么他有多大程度上意识到这一点？他非常清楚，因为我们知道，即使在文化大革命的最后几年，中国也在进行新市场的经济实验，同时也为劳动力提供了新的激励措施。事实证明，对于中国来说，这是一个非常有帮助的组合，即在市场被允许做什么以及在国家指令性经济下必须移交什么方面改变国家方向。同时也为农民、工人和小企业提供了激励，使他们能够创造一种新的私营部门驱动的经济
as well. And in doing that, he and the other members of the leadership are very much aware that the size of China's labor force is immensely important as part of that. It's worth noting that one of the elements of that, which again has slightly been underplayed, is of course the importance of women workers. Because if you think about one of the images that perhaps you associate more than anything else with China's economic experimentation during that period, what sometimes we call the economic miracle, the building of factories, which then become a workshop to the world, the made in China phenomenon. When you look at pictures of who's working in those factories in the 70s and 80s, it's very frequently young women in their
也是如此。在这样做的过程中，他和领导层的其他成员非常清楚，中国劳动力的规模作为其中的一部分是非常重要的。值得注意的是，其中一个被稍微低估的因素当然是女性工人的重要性。因为如果你想到一个你可能比任何其他事物都更与中国那一时期的经济实验联系在一起的形象，我们有时称之为经济奇迹，即工厂的建设，这些工厂后来成为了世界工厂，“中国制造”现象。当你看到70年代和80年代在这些工厂工作的人的照片时，经常是十几岁、二十出头的年轻女性。
late teens, early 20s. They're coming out from the countryside. They are part of that vast, you know, not exactly untapped, but undertapped workforce that finds new opportunities. On the one hand, the conditions that they find are deeply, deeply exploitative. Even today, Chinese factories are not always particularly pleasant places to work and can be very dangerous. But they also provide a new phenomenon of women who are able to actually earn in their own right, become part of the labor force in their own right. And you can see the origins there of something which actually is now very noticeable in China, which is a distinct female labor force. And that, of course, has also been part of that wider communist and socialist tradition. Although it's honored as
她们从农村出来。她们是那庞大的、你知道，不完全是未开发，但开发不足的劳动力的一部分，她们找到了新的机会。一方面，她们所处的环境是非常、非常剥削性的。即使在今天，中国的工厂也不总是特别令人愉快的工作场所，而且可能非常危险。但她们也提供了一种新的现象，即女性能够真正靠自己的能力赚钱，成为劳动力的一部分。你可以在那里看到现在在中国非常明显的东西的起源，那就是独特的女性劳动力。当然，这也是更广泛的共产主义和社会主义传统的一部分。虽然它在
much in the breach as in the observance, it's clear that the emancipation of women, which means in the labor market as much as anywhere else, was always part of the Chinese communist agenda. And you could argue that the women being brought into the factories at that time were one aspect of that communist legacy, which was being put into actual operation at that time. Runny, you mentioned how China becomes the workshop of the world. To be the workshop of the world, you have to be open to the world, which of course, in the 60s, under the Cultural Revolution, China absolutely hadn't been. I guess the paradigmatic image of that process of opening up is Dan going to America, going to a rodeo and wearing a Stetson. But am I right that actually one of the key
违背中受到的尊重和在遵守中一样多，但很明显，妇女解放，这意味着在劳动力市场和其他任何地方一样，一直是中共议程的一部分。你可以说，当时被带进工厂的女性是那种共产主义遗产的一个方面，当时正在付诸实施。拉纳，你提到了中国是如何成为世界工厂的。要成为世界工厂，你必须向世界开放，这当然是60年代在文化大革命下中国绝对没有做到的。我想这种开放过程的范式形象是邓小平去美国，去参加牛仔竞技表演并戴着牛仔帽。但我说得对吗，实际上这个过程中的关键人物之一，我提到了威猛乐队，这是邀请威猛乐队、乔治·迈克尔和安德鲁·里奇利访问中国的人，是一个叫赵紫阳的人。他在文化上非常重要，但在经济上在自由化和开放中国方面也很重要。所以你认为他在这个故事中有多重要？赵紫阳几乎是中国1980年代经济现代化和全球化故事中缺失的一环。他本质上，你几乎可以称他为1980年代中期（87年至89年）的中国总理。他是中国共产党的总书记，这是一种更准确的说法。但他也是那个时期最激进的经济自由化者，在某种程度上也是政治自由化者。他与邓小平非常、非常亲近，
figures in this process, I mentioned Wham, this is the man who invites Wham, George Michael and Andrew Ridgely to tour China, is a guy called Zhao Xiangiyang. And he's very important culturally, but also economically in liberalizing and opening up China. So how important do you think he is to this story? Zhao Ziyang is almost the missing element to the story of China's economic modernization and globalization in the 1980s. He was essentially, you might almost call him the prime minister of China during the middle of the 1980s, 87 to 89. He was general secretary of the Chinese Communist Party, that's a more accurate way to put it. But he was the most radical economic liberalizer, and to some extent, political liberalizer during that period as well. He was very, very close to Deng Xiaoping,
因为邓小平像毛泽东一样，当时必须处理党内的不同派系。值得注意的是，当时有一个相当大的、更保守的经济派系，在不想过多偏离指令性经济方面是保守的。像陈云这样的人物就处于那个特定的位置。所以并不是说邓小平一切都随心所欲。他需要像胡耀邦这样的相对自由派，他在中国经济初期担任总书记，同时也开启了一种政治，这种政治在西方世界理解的意义上不是民主的，但尽管如此，他还是想要一个更开放的公民社会，更多地批评政府和媒体的自由，也允许更多地向地方下放权力。所以这种遗产变得非常
because Deng Xiaoping, like Mao, had to deal with different factions within the party at that time. And there was, it's worth noting, a very considerable, more conservative economic faction, conservative in the terms of not wanting to move away from the command economy too much. Figures like Chen Yun sat in that particular position. So it's not as if Deng Xiaoping had everything his own way. And he needed relative liberals, both politically and economically, like Hu Yaobang, who was the general secretary at the beginning of the Chinese economy, as well as also opening up a politics which was not democratic in the sense that we'd understand it in the western world, but nonetheless wanted a more open civil society, more freedom to criticize the government and the press, and also allowed more devolution of power to localities as well. So that legacy became tremendously
对当时中国经济改革发生的方式至关重要。我再次向你推荐历史学家朱利安·格维茨（Julian Gewirtz），他最近的著作《永不回头》（Never Turn Back）是赵紫阳的传记，本质上是将他放回了邓小平的故事中。所以别误会我，没有邓小平，我们就不会有全面的改革。他绝对是负责人。他绝对是设定旅行方向的人。但赵紫阳是执行者，是直到1989年一直踩着经济改革和向美国及其他地方市场开放油门的人，同时也研究了中国经济的民用和军用部门如何能更成功地相互作用。这是另一个当然在今天也有一些相关性的因素。所以明显的对比是苏联发生的事情，那里的改革不起作用，实际上摧毁了国家。我看到有人争辩说，在中国有效的一个原因是
central to the way in which the Chinese economic reforms happened during that time. And again, I refer you to the historian Julian Gewirtz, whose most recent book, Never Turn Back, is a biography of Zhao Ziyang, essentially putting him back into the Deng Xiaoping story. So don't get me wrong, without Deng Xiaoping, we would not have had the overall reforms. He was definitely the man in charge. He was definitely the guy who set the direction of travel. But Zhao Ziyang is the implementer, the person who actually, until 1989, was putting his foot on the accelerator of economic reform and opening up to markets in America and elsewhere, as well as actually looking at areas like the civilian and military sections of the Chinese economy could interact with each other more successfully. Another element which, of course, has some relevance in the present day. So the obvious contrast is with what happens in the Soviet Union, where the reform doesn't work and actually destroys the state. I've seen it argued that one reason that it works in China
而在苏联却不行，是因为在中国，改革往往是自下而上的。它们不仅仅是由坐在首都委员会桌旁的人驱动，向各省发号施令，或者用可能实际上消散地方精英权力的改革让地方精英感到惊讶。地方精英不喜欢它们。那是对的吗？其中一些改革是由农村和各个地方、省份或城镇正在发生的事情驱动的吗？是的，绝对是。目前在这一特定领域最活跃的辩论之一
and not in the Soviet Union is that in China, often the reforms are from the bottom up, as it were. They're not just being driven by people sitting around a kind of committee table in the capital city dictating to the provinces or surprising local elites with reforms that may actually dissipate the local elite's power. The local elites don't like them. Is that right? Are some of these reforms being driven out by what's going on out in the countryside and individual localities or provinces or towns or whatever? Yes, absolutely. One of the liveliest debates at the moment in this particular
关于中国的学术研究是，那一时期的经济增长在多大程度上本质上是一种草根现象，在多大程度上是由国家指导的。我认为很明显，你必须给两者一定程度的赞誉。一方面，很明显，中国农民在农村有一种创业精神，即想要种植作物并在市场上出售，这与当时俄罗斯大部分地区似乎正在发生的事情非常不同，在某种意义上，社会主义制度在那里运作的时间要长得多。但同样公平地说，邓小平和那些本质上实施重大改革的领导人，例如创造了那些市场运作的能力，
field of academic research on China is how much the economic growth of that period was essentially a grassroots phenomenon and how much was directed by the state. And I think it's clear that you have to give some level of credit to both. On the one hand, it's clear that the Chinese peasants had in the countryside a level of entrepreneurship in terms of wanting to grow crops and sell it on the market that was quite different from what seemed to be going on in most of Russia at that time, where the socialist system had operated for a much longer basis in a sense. But also, it's fair to say that Deng Xiaoping and the other leaders who essentially implemented major reforms in terms of creating, for instance, the ability for those markets to operate,
你知道，市场，尽管一些新自由主义者可能会告诉你，并不会凭空出现。正如我认为香港的一位伟大改革者约翰·考珀斯韦特（John Cowperthwaite）所说，创造自由放任需要大量的政府努力。在这种情况下，显然情况就是这样，政府花了很多时间研究如何改变从税收激励到本质上创造营销网络，你知道，交通基础设施等等，这将允许营销发生。所以两者绝对都有作用。但我认为，再次使用一个中国术语可能值得注意，这个术语今天仍在使用，但在当时非常普遍，
you know, markets, despite what some neoliberals might tell you, don't simply emerge out of nowhere. As I think one of the great reformers of Hong Kong, John Cuperthwaite, I think, put it, it takes an awful lot of government effort to create laissez-faire. And in this case, that was clearly the case that the government spent a great deal of time working out how to change everything from tax incentives to essentially creating marketing networks, you know, transport infrastructure and so forth that would allow marketing to take place. So both absolutely had a role. But I think it might be notable to, again, take a Chinese term, which was still used today, but very common at the time,
来描述当时中国人自己是如何看待创业的。他们称之为“下海”。这字面意思是跳进海里。我认为这是一个非常有力的隐喻，因为它既暗示了一些令人振奋的事情，也可能，你知道，可能导致各种机会，但它也是危险的。我认为，这种实际实验并非保证成功的理解在当时是被理解的。那个隐喻实际上表达得很好。但尽管如此，事实证明，从政府实施所谓的经济特区，很多人蜂拥而至，因为他们知道真正进行这种创业工作的条件要好得多，到政府基本上也退后一步，基本上说，好吧，从技术上讲，
to describe how the Chinese themselves thought of entrepreneurship at this time. They called it xiahai. That literally means jumping into the sea. And I think that's a very powerful metaphor, because it suggests both something that's exhilarating and potentially, you know, could lead to all sorts of opportunities, but it's also dangerous. And I think the understanding that this actual experiment was not something that was guaranteed success was understood at the time. That metaphor actually expresses that quite well. But nonetheless, as it turned out, a combination of everything from the government implementing so-called special economic zones. Lots of people flocked because they knew that the conditions for actually doing this kind of entrepreneurship work were much better, to the government basically also sort of getting back and basically saying, well, technically,
你知道，这些人违反了这条税法，或者他们可能违反了这项规定。但看，我们暂时先不管它。有时会稍微开玩笑地指出，这是印度没有在同一时间起飞的原因之一，因为市场规模相同，巨大的创业精神。但有时人们说，本质上，印度对经济的繁荣限制太多，而中国可能不够。但短期效果，肯定在中国，是让经济本质上狂飙。在1980年代，我们看到了这种效果，即中国国内市场以及向世界其他地区出口能力的快速增长。拉纳，你提到了“下海”这个想法作为这一时期的重要隐喻。
you know, these people are breaking this tax law, or they're probably violating this regulation. But look, let's just leave it for the moment. It's sometimes slightly jokingly pointed out as one of the reasons why India didn't take off at the same time, because same size of market, huge entrepreneurship. But sometimes people say that essentially, India had too much red tape on the economy, and China had maybe not enough. But the short term effect, certainly in China, was to let the economy essentially go rip. And in the 1980s, we saw the effect of that in terms of the rapid growth that was seen in China's domestic market and also its capacity to export to the rest of the world. Ron, you mentioned this idea of jumping into the sea as an important metaphor in this period.
这也是一部极具影响力的英语电视连续剧《河殇》的主题，不是吗？它将围绕黄河成长起来的中华文明，就像黄河本身一样，是什么？那句话，它是七分泥沙，一分水。而且它是堵塞的，它是污染的，重要的事情是跳进黄河之外的蓝色开放海洋。换句话说，几乎是加入西方世界。而且我的意思是，这应该在电视上播放真是令人难以置信。而且我猜，这被放映的事实本身就证明了你不能真正拥有经济……嗯，或者你能吗？我的意思是，这是一个关于中国的伟大问题。但80年代的假设是，如果你正在
It's also the theme, isn't it, of an incredibly influential TV series in English, River Elegy, which casts Chinese civilization which had grown up around the Yellow River, as the Yellow River itself is, what is it? The phrase, it's kind of seven parts mud and one part water. And that this is clogged up, that it's polluted, that the vital thing is to get out into the blue open oceans that lie beyond the Yellow River. In other words, to join the Western world, almost. And I mean, it's incredible that this should be put on TV. And I guess the very fact that this is screened testifies to the way in which you can't really have economic... Well, or can you? I mean, this is a great question about China. But the presumption is in the 80s that if you're
进行经济自由化，你也必须进行文化自由化。绝对是。我实际上在我的书《一点革命》（A Bit of Revolution）中写过，你亲切地提到了它，我会坚持这一点，这可能是任何国家播放过的最重要的电视连续剧。它可能被1亿或更多的观众看到。它只在1988年夏天播放过两次。这是一件非常奇怪的事情。它有点像纪录片，但它也是评论。它汇集了中国一些最聪明的自由派知识分子，谈论他们如何必须本质上放弃过去的陈词滥调。这非常大胆。
having economic liberalization, you have to have cultural liberalization as well. Absolutely. I have written actually in my book, A Bit of Revolution, which you kindly mentioned, would stick by it, that this maybe is the most important television series that's ever been broadcast in any country. It was seen by possibly 100 million or more viewers. It was only ever shown twice in the summer of 1988. And it's a very odd thing. It's sort of a documentary, but it's also a commentary. It brought together some of China's brightest liberal intellectuals talking about how they had to essentially abandon the shibboleths of the past. It was very daring.
他们谈论驱逐虚假的农民皇帝。那就是毛泽东。我的意思是，在1988年的中国国家电视台谈论这个是令人震惊的。相反，谈论拥抱蓝色海洋，当然意味着美国，当然，在那个时候，本质上是一个默契的盟友。还有香港。是的，人们对香港作为一种转口贸易地也很感兴趣。但更广泛的世界，换句话说，中国开放以拥抱外部世界。使用的隐喻是，黄河，那是一条暴力的、内向的
They talked about casting out the false peasant emperor. And that was Mao. I mean, to talk about that on national Chinese TV in 1988 was astonishing. And instead talked about embracing the blue ocean, meaning, of course, the United States, which, of course, at that point was essentially a tacit ally. And also Hong Kong. Yes, there was also an interest in Hong Kong as a sort of entrepot place as well. But the wider world more generally, in other words, China opening up to embrace the outside world. The metaphor that was used was that the river, the Yellow River, which was a violent, inward-looking
力量，必须被放弃，转而跳进深蓝色海洋的海里。我们应该说，赵紫阳，总理，我们提到的党总书记，经济上的自由化者，出现在第六集，时间不长，但你确实看到了他，这表明他本质上给予了默契的支持。我们现在知道，他和盟友在政治局为重播这部电视剧进行了非常激烈的争论，而更保守的成员则强烈反对。几年后，出于我们当然会在1989年讨论的原因，它被禁了。对，因为那是1988年出来的。当然，1989年发生的事情是邓小平实验的重大危机点，也就是一系列事件，最终导致了
force, had to be abandoned in favor of jumping into the sea of the deep blue ocean. And we should say that Zhao Ziyang, the prime minister, the general secretary of the party who we mentioned, the liberaliser in economics, appears in episode six, not for very long, but you do see him, which was an indication that he had essentially given tacit support. We now know that he and other allies argued very hard in the Politburo for a repeat showing of this TV series, whereas the more conservative members were deeply against it. And a couple of years later, for reasons we'll discuss, of course, in 1989, it was banned. Right, because that comes out in 1988. And of course, what happens in 1989 is the great crisis point for Deng's experiment, which is the series of events that culminates in the
天安门广场的可怕屠杀。那么你看到了那里发生的对抗吗？我的意思是，最生动和著名地由那个站在天安门广场坦克队列前拿着购物袋的不知名男子所体现。你认为那是必须发生的事情吗？那是中国80年代进行的改革过程中硬性规定的吗？不，我不认为1989年有什么必然性。事实上，领导层中有相对自由派，胡耀邦，我提到过他最终被踢出局，还有赵紫阳，表明有可用的替代途径。简而言之，值得注意的是背景
terrible massacre in Tiananmen Square. So do you see the confrontation that happens there? I mean, most vividly and famously exemplified by the unknown man with his shopping bag standing in front of the line of tanks in Tiananmen Square. Do you see that as something that had to happen that was kind of hard-baked into the process of reforms being carried out in China in the 80s? No, I don't think there was anything inevitable about 1989. And the fact that you had relative liberals in the leadership, Hu Yaobang, I've mentioned he was eventually kicked out, and Zhao Ziyang, shows that there were alternative pathways that were available. Just briefly, it's worth noting that the background
到1989年，当然，部分是关于对更大政治开放的渴望，当然受到多米尼克提到过几次的戈尔巴乔夫访问的启发。他那年春天访问北京，那是示威活动的触发点之一。但此外，实际上，经济状况，我提到过那种高速发展的经济。嗯，产品之一是通货膨胀，巨大的通货膨胀，这基本上使得靠官方工资生活变得更加困难，这是许多中产阶级抗议者、学生和其他人走上街头的原因，因为他们实际上字面上负担不起维持日常生活的费用。所有这些都与更自由的领导部分，包括赵紫阳，试图调解结合在一起。
to 1989, of course, was partly about the desire for greater political openness, inspired, of course, by the visit of Gorbachev, who Dominic has mentioned a couple of times. He was visiting Beijing in the spring of that year, and that was one of the triggers for the demonstrations. But in addition, actually, the economic situation, I've mentioned the kind of go-go economy. Well, one of the products was inflation, and huge inflation, which basically was making it harder to live on official salaries, was a reason that many of those middle class protesters, the students and others, came out onto the streets because they actually literally couldn't afford to keep their day-to-day lives going. And all of that came together with essentially an attempt to mediate on the part of the more liberal parts of the leadership, including Zhao Ziyang.
李鹏，后来成为总理，更加强硬，想要基本上关闭这些示威活动。但值得注意的是，中国不同地区有不同的反应。上海和其他城市也有大规模示威。当时的市委书记，一个叫江泽民的人，后来当然成为了中国国家主席，实际上设法在没有暴力对抗的情况下平息了示威。所以显然这是可以做到的。最终北京遭受1989年6月（6月3日和4日）工人和学生屠杀悲剧的原因之一是，最高领导层内部的战斗、争吵变得几乎无法解决。本质上，邓小平最终站在了支持强硬派的一边，他们会派坦克，他们会派士兵，
Li Peng, who became the prime minister, much more hardline, wanted to basically shut down these demonstrations. But it's worth noting that different parts of China had different reactions. Shanghai, along with other cities, also had major demonstrations. the party chief at the time, a man named Jiang Zemin, who would go on the course to become China's president, actually managed to calm the demonstrations down without a violent confrontation. So clearly it could be done. One of the reasons in the end that Beijing suffered the tragedy of the massacre of the workers and students in June 1989, June the 3rd and 4th, was that the battles, the quarrels within the top leadership became almost insoluble. And essentially, Deng Xiaoping, in the end, came down on the side of saying he was going to back the hardliners, and they would send in tanks, they would send in soldiers,
他们会结束这些示威活动。结果，赵紫阳，那位更自由的总书记，被逮捕，基本上在流亡中度过了他余生的16年，直到去世，再也不允许担任任何政治职务。所以邓小平有他的选择并做出了选择，但它们并非不可避免。邓小平在多大程度上受到影响？他最终站在强硬派一边，他说，好吧，无论在北京付出什么代价都要关闭这件事。他受到东欧正在发生的事情以及他能看到显然将在苏联展开的事情的影响有多大？所以他在多大程度上在想，好吧，他们在那里完全失去了对政治进程的控制。我不会犯同样的错误。他并不完全受到那个影响
and they would bring these demonstrations to an end. And as a result, Zhao Ziyang, the more liberal general secretary, was arrested and basically spent the next 16 years of his life until he died playing golf in exile, never allowed to hold a political post again. So Deng Xiaoping had his choices and made them, but they were not inevitable. And how much is Deng influenced? The fact that he ends up siding with the hardliners and he says, OK, shut this thing down no matter what it takes in Beijing. How much is he influenced by what's happening in Eastern Europe and what he can see is clearly going to unfold in the Soviet Union? So how much is he thinking, well, they've completely lost control of the political process there. I'm not going to make the same mistake. He's not entirely influenced by that
因为如果我们只记得顺序，1989年6月4日，坦克进入北京中心、平民被杀的那一天，是波兰举行首次大部分自由选举的同一天，波兰随后将成为1989年夏天和秋天一系列变化的一部分。但这在当时并没有被看到。当时，波兰被视为东欧一个稍微大胆的实验。在那个时候，东德人和其他人并不认为他们是脆弱的。所以有一种意识，我们现在肯定知道在政治局，对戈尔巴乔夫和这些改革的警惕，他们是否真的会成功。但绝大多数讨论是内部的。这更多地与文化大革命的记忆有关。这是领导层
because if we just remember the sequencing, the 4th of June, 1989, the day that the tanks moved into central Beijing and the civilians were killed is the same date as the first mostly free elections in Poland, which then would go on to become part of a wave of changes over the summer and autumn of 1989. But that wasn't seen at the time. At the time, Poland was seen as a slightly daring experiment in Eastern Europe. And at that point, East Germans and others didn't think that they were vulnerable. So there was an awareness, certainly we now know in the Politburo, a wariness of Gorbachev and these reforms, whether they were really going to work out. But the vast majority of the discussion was internal. It was much more to do with actually the memory of the Cultural Revolution. This was the leadership
群体，仅仅15年前，他们刚刚走出他们所见过的最大动荡的余波。记得邓小平的儿子，正如我所说，因此终身残疾。看到街上的这些示威者让他们认为，我们不能允许那种混乱再次发生。完全误导的解释，但尽管如此，是他们的解释。因为这发生在天安门广场，那曾是人们会来挥舞毛泽东红宝书和一切的伟大地方。我的意思是，这是它发生在北京天安门广场而不是其他地方的原因之一吗，因为位置的中心性？是的。天安门广场是绝对的象征和政治
group who just 15 years before had been coming out of the aftermath of the greatest turmoil they had ever seen. Remember Deng Xiaoping's son, as I said, was crippled for life as a result. And seeing these demonstrators in the street made them think, we cannot allow that chaos to happen again. Completely misleading interpretation, but nonetheless, their interpretation. Because it's happening in Tiananmen Square, which had been the great kind of place where people would come and wave mouths at a red book and everything. I mean, is that one of the reasons why it happens in Tiananmen Square in Beijing in a way that it doesn't happen elsewhere because of the centrality of the location? Yes. Tiananmen Square is the absolute symbolic and political
中国的中心，当然还有紫禁城在那里。别忘了它也是唯一拥有所有那些外国电视摄制组和记者的中心，这就是为什么示威者以其他城市没有的方式留在那里。但也值得记住的是，大约在四月、五月，多达一百万人的示威高峰已经减少。我们谈论的是到那个阶段广场上还有几千人，但那是最终不想离开的最后群体。而那正是邓小平派坦克去对付的群体。所以在那之后，说邓小平变成了一个稍微保守的人物，对改革更加警惕，是公平的吗？还是邓小平在70年代末和80年代初一直到他结束
center of China with the Forbidden City, of course, there. Don't forget also it was the only place that had all those foreign television crews and reporters, which is why demonstrators remained there in a way that they didn't in other cities. But it's also worth remembering that the height of the demonstrations in about May, April, May, of up to a million people had dwindled. We're talking about a few thousands were still in the square by that stage, but that was the final group that in the end didn't want to move on. And that was the group against whom Deng Xiaoping sent the tanks. And so in the aftermath of that, is it fair to say that Deng becomes a slightly more conservative figure, more wary of reform, or is there a basic continuity between Deng in the late 70s and early 80s right through to the end of his
作为最高领导人的任期之间存在基本连续性？我认为这在某种意义上更有趣，多米尼克，因为你在邓小平统治的最后几年看到的是绝对更强硬的政治立场。90年代初任何向更多自由主义和开放的举动都被冻结，尤其是因为领导层中的保守派，像陈云和李鹏这样的人，本质上走到邓小平面前说，看看你做了什么。我们在党内经历了一次濒死体验。但它也做了什么，尽管他必须为此保持安静几年，是让邓小平绝对确定经济自由化不会脱轨。换句话说，他牺牲了当时进行任何重大政治变革的自由，从他的角度来看，这些在当时是站不住脚的
tenure as the paramount leader? I think it's more interesting than that in a sense, Dominic, because what you see in the last years of Deng Xiaoping's rule is a combination absolutely of a more hardline political stance. Any moves certainly in the early 90s towards more liberalism and openness are frozen, not least because conservatives in leadership, people like Chen Yun and Li Peng, essentially go to Deng Xiaoping and say, look what you did. We had a near-death experience in the party. But what it also does, although he has to keep a bit quiet about it for a couple of years, is make Deng Xiaoping absolutely determined that the economic liberalization is not going to be derailed. In other words, he sacrifices the freedom at that time to have any major political changes, which are not tenable at that point from his point of
观点，说，但我不会让经济改革死亡。1992年，仅仅三年后，他进行了后来被称为“南巡”的活动。这是一个在中国古典中用来指皇帝巡视中国南方的术语，到建立了自由市场区的经济特区，经济增长再次泵动，出口正在为世界其他地区生产，并利用他最后的那种信誉，这是巨大的信誉，在公众以及政治局中，说，我们可能会在政治上进行打击，但经济变革不会结束。基本上，1989年到1992年之间发生的经济自由化低迷，又回到了前进档。然后我们再次看到了我们现在所知道的令人震惊的
view, to saying, but I'm not going to let the economic reforms die. And in 1992, just three years later, he undertakes what becomes known as the Nanxun, the Southern Tour. It's a term that's used in classical Chinese to mean the tour of the emperor to the south of China, to the special economic zones where the free market zones have been set up, where economic growth is once again pumping, where the exports are being produced for the rest of the world, and makes it clear using his last sort of credit, and it's huge credit, with the wider public, as well as with the Politburo, to say, we may crack down politically, but the economic changes are not going to end. And basically, the downturn in economic liberalization, which had happened between about 1989 and 1992, it returns to forward gear. And then again, we see what we now know was an astonishing
1990年代和2000年代的增长期，其中在不同点上，中国每年发布了大约10%的经济增长率。所以这就是邓小平给中国经济留下的最后遗产，1992年的那次南巡。所以拉纳，在天安门广场，赵紫阳，后来被清洗去打高尔夫球，他最后一次露面，他会见了一些学生，他有这句名言。不像你们，他告诉学生，我们已经老了，不重要了。然后他向他们鞠躬，学生们开始鼓掌。然后那是他作为中国官员最后一次在公众面前被看到。当你看着邓小平，邓小平是一个非常、非常老的人。他去世时大约130岁。他去世时看起来像尤达。他是一个非常干瘪的老人。确实。我想他无论如何都活到了健康的94岁，
period of growth in the 1990s and 2000s, in which at various points, China posted something like a 10% economic growth rate every year. So that was Deng Xiaoping's last legacy to the Chinese economy, that tour of the South of China in 1992. So Rana, in Tiananmen Square, Zhao Xiang, who then gets Persian taken off to play golf, his last appearance, he meets with some students and he has this famous line. Unlike you, he tells the students, we are already old and do not matter. And then he bows before them and the students begin to applaud. And then that's the last time he's kind of seen in public as a Chinese official. When you look at Deng, Deng was an old, old man. He was about 130 by the time he died. He looks like Yoda by the time he died. He was a very wizened old man. Indeed. I think he clocked in about a healthy 94 anyway,
所以是私有化风格的94岁。但你可以争辩说他是一个深刻的革命人物，所以他确实很重要。绝对是。邓小平生前的一个绰号是“钢铁厂”。换句话说，人们说他是无尽的，就他而言，政治能量的源泉，而且非常强硬。他是一个知道自己想要什么并且不会停止前进的人。最终，他想要的实际上是所有中国领导人，共产主义者、非共产主义者，都想要的，那就是中国成为世界上的一种强大国家，拥有一个能让人民生活下去的繁荣社会。他选择体现这一点的方式是通过采取各种政治主张，从社会主义
so a privatised style 94. But you could argue that he is a profoundly revolutionary figure, and so he really does matter. Absolutely. One of Deng Xiaoping's nicknames in life was the steel mill. In other words, people said that he was an unbounded source of, in his case, political energy and hard as nails. He was someone who knew what he wanted and just would not stop going. And in the end, what he wanted was actually what all Chinese leaders, communist, non-communist, have wanted, which is China to be a kind of powerful state in the world, to have a prosperous society that can keep its people going. And the way that he chose to exemplify that was through taking a whole variety of political strands, something from the socialist
传统，他绝对坚持到最后几天，从他认为可能有效的资本主义世界中汲取一些东西，导致了那句名言，我们应该把它放进去，他谈论不同类型的经济体系，据说说过，不管黑猫白猫，只要能抓到老鼠就是好猫。这是一个非常务实的意识形态人物的声明。这必须与这样一个事实形成对比，即当涉及到任何看起来像系统垮台的事情时，他不是戈尔巴乔夫。他是那个最终决定他会使用强制暴力并且确实使用了强制暴力的人
tradition, which he absolutely adhered to, to his last days, something from the capitalist world that he felt could be effective, leading to that famous statement, we should put it in there, that he was talking about different types of economic system, and is supposed to have said, it doesn't matter if a cat is a black cat or a white cat, as long as it catches mice, it's a good cat. That is a statement of a very pragmatic sort of ideological figure. And that has to be contrasted with the fact that when it came to anything that might look like the downfall of the system, he was not Gorbachev. He was the man who in the end decided that he would use coercive violence and did use coercive violence
每当他觉得系统受到威胁时。1989年就是一个例子。还有一个简短的值得一提，因为人们往往记得较少。它发生在1975年早些时候，当时在他文化大革命期间短暂掌权期间，一个小村庄叫沙甸。那里基本上发生了围攻。他派出了军队，这实际上导致了1600人的死亡，包括300名儿童和老人在那次对抗中基本上被杀。他在那种情况下那样做，因为动机是一样的，即任何反对
whenever he felt the system was threatened. And 1989 is one example of that. There's just one brief one that it's worth mentioning because people tend to remember it less. It happened earlier in 1975 when during one of his brief periods in power in the Cultural Revolution, a little village called them Shadian. And there was basically a siege there. And he sent in troops, which actually led to the deaths of 1,600 people, including 300 children and elderly people were basically killed during that confrontation. And he did that in that case, because the motivation was the same, the idea that anyone who stands against the
中国共产党的人本质上必须付出代价。所以对于那些愿意付出代价的人，比如华国锋，他可以相当仁慈。但他经济上务实的意愿从未与那种务实主义可能允许中国共产主义体系以任何方式崩溃或被侵蚀的想法相匹配。我认为，这总结了邓小平。嗯，拉纳，那绝对太棒了，我敢说，是一次杰作。汤姆和我经常在这个播客上争论个人政治家、个人领导人有多重要。但我认为即使是我，因为我通常会嘲笑他们，我认为你有时必须承认个人确实可以产生巨大的差异。而邓小平当然是其中之一。而你也是这个播客上的其中之一，拉纳，不是吗，汤姆？
Chinese Communist Party has to essentially pay the price. So for those who are willing to pay the price, like Hua Guofeng, he could be quite merciful. But his economic willingness to be pragmatic was never matched with the idea that that pragmatism could allow the Chinese communist system in any way to fall apart or be eroded. And that, I think, sums up Deng Xiaoping. Well, Rana, that was absolutely wonderful, dare I say, a tour de force. Tom and I often debate on this podcast how much individual politicians, how much individual leaders matter. But I think even I, because I normally poo-poo them, I think you have to concede sometimes that single individuals can make a massive difference. And Dung is certainly one of them. And you are one of them on this podcast, Rana, isn't he, Tom?
是的。违背我们对马克思主义历史的倾向。我会在这个特定情况下指出，只要你们两个负责，我的心绝对是安定的。啊，那很好。嗯，我们非常把自己看作是这个播客中的那种伟大结构力量，拉纳。我们是革命的舵手。对。但你是我们不会摆脱和退休的赵紫阳。嗯，在这种情况下，我会说这算是一个毛泽东非对抗性矛盾的完美例子。
Yes. Bucking our trend to Marxist history. I will, in this particular case, point out that as long as the two of you are in charge, my heart is definitely at ease. Ah, that's good. Well, we see ourselves very much as the kind of great structural forces, Rana, in this podcast. We're the helmsmen of the revolution. Right. But you're the Zhao's Yang who we're not going to get rid of and retire. Well, in that case, I will say that this counts as a perfect example of a Maoist non-antagonistic contradiction.
太棒了。辉煌。历史的教训。拉纳，非常感谢你。也感谢汤姆，感谢大家的收听，我们很快就会回来，无论是马克思主义历史
Wonderful. Splendid. The lessons of history. Rana, thank you so much. And thank you, much and thank you everyone for listening and we'll be back very soon whether it will be Marxist history
还是多米尼克对伟大人物历史的新热情，我们拭目以待，但我们会回来的，再见，再见，谢谢，我是玛丽娜·海德。
or whether it will be Dominic's newfound enthusiasm for great man history we will see but we will be back bye bye goodbye and thanks I'm Marina Hyde
或者多米尼克对伟人史的新热情是否会持续，我们拭目以待，但我们会回来的，再见，再见，谢谢，我是玛丽娜·海德。
and I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，为您讲述其背后的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。